[Music]
this year the holiday shopping struggle
has been real more tech products have
either been sold out or have longer wait
times than usual but after several
failed attempts to place an order i
finally got one of the hot ticket items
on my list
a nintendo switch so what helped me get
it inventory tracking apps
inventory tracking apps send users
alerts across a wide range of retailers
so think amazon walmart target for
example on top of typical holiday
shortages that we see this time of year
due to increased demand this year we're
dealing with an ongoing computer chip
crisis which hurt inventory levels last
holiday season and it's bleeding into
this one that's a big reason why a lot
of these products have either been sold
out or out of stock for months now in
fact adobe analytics data says that
shoppers saw more than 2 billion out of
stock messages this holiday season and
that's a 325 rise over pre-pandemic
levels and it probably won't get better
for months now or maybe even longer i
can't sit there and manually refresh
everything it's just impossible so you
use the tools at hand and that's what
people do that's justin vavrick and he
created nowinstock.net one of many
websites that send inventory tracking
alerts he says there are two main ways
for tracker sites to know when an item
is in stock one is to partner with a
retailer to tap into its website code
also known as its application
programming interface or api api is
basically like you're making a request
to a database
and you receive an answer you say i want
the information about this product and
it returns you a predetermined
set of values and you can use those
values to
determine whether an item's in stock and
like justin's site other platforms use
similar methods to find in-demand
products another way sites find in-stock
items is with a scraper tool which
periodically checks a retailer's website
for subtle changes those can be tweaks
in its url or other not so obvious
changes to online shoppers scrapers can
also pick up if a website banner changes
from out of stock to in stock or from
out of stock to add to cart then
algorithms can let users know what's
available the content directorate
brickseek another stock monitoring
platform told me that the company
monitors inventory nationally and checks
product codes locally to help people
find the items that they're after even
if it's not something that we're
necessarily notified of proactively our
system in the background is constantly
24 7
checking and rechecking across the
nation all of those different products
in our product catalog constantly
updating the information about what
those price points are so after hearing
about all these apps and websites i
realized i needed to create accounts so
i made an account with hot stock and zoo
alert trying to place an order for a ps5
which i'm still actually trying to get
and a nintendo switch while initially i
was getting alerts for both of them
quite often i've only been able to get
the nintendo switch pretty quickly into
the process i realized that the biggest
limitation was actually me i just
couldn't pull the trigger fast enough to
place the order experts tell me that
that's largely because i'm competing
against automated buying bots which
scoop in and buy up all the merchandise
faster than humans can and they resell
the merchandise on websites like amazon
and ebay but for more money the problem
lies in the fact that
they're so quick
that
when there's enough of them running they
can basically snap up all the inventory
with that problem in mind i started
reaching out to people online who got
the items that i was after but by using
inventory tracking apps and websites
that's how i found maurice who used hot
stock to find a ps5 as soon as the link
came up on my hot stock app i clicked on
it it took me to you know the walmart
app and then it automatically loaded up
the uh the ps5 actually something
similar happened to me it took several
failed attempts before i was able to add
a nintendo switch to my cart i just
couldn't add it fast enough it happened
early one morning i got a random
notification from hot stock saying go to
gamestop's website and that the nintendo
switch was in stock so i went to the
website was able to add it to cart and
check out without a problem a week later
the box arrived on my doorstep here are
some tips on how to get inventory
tracking apps to work better for you
number one if you're using one of these
turn on your alerts including the
notifications on your smartphone two
turn on your sound overnight if your
phones on vibrate when retailers are
updating their stock at midnight or
later you won't hear those alerts
hotstock for example can send a push
notification to your web browser while
nowinstock.net might send you a push
notification on your smartphone or a
text message three be open to using
multiple devices sometimes your
smartphone might get a notification and
show it to you faster than your laptop
for instance and maybe your laptop gets
that notification faster than your
desktop computer it all depends oh and
if your phone is on low power mode turn
that off sometimes that slows down how
quickly your notifications might pop up
on your smartphone and if it's paired
with your apple watch it might slow down
how quickly you see that notification on
your watch four create accounts with all
the major retailers selling the item
that you're after or that would be
selling it if it wasn't sold out the
checkout process runs a lot smoother if
the retailer already has your credit
card information your name and phone
number so make sure you enter all of
that information in the app before you
even start and lastly be diligent it's
gonna take a couple tries before you get
the item that you want unless you're
really lucky or unless you hire someone
to create some bots for you
if you guys are on this mission or have
gotten the items that you're after using
inventory tracking apps comment below
and let me know also be sure to
subscribe to stay up to date on all the
latest tech gadgets and the industry
that's powering them until next time
[Music]